playstation september showcase just
wrapped up and we finally got to see
gameplay of god of war ragnarok as well
as getting an announcement of a star
wars knights of the old republic remake
my name is davonte chiselman come on
let's talk about it let's talk about all
of this
first off
wow so let's start with the end of the
showcase where after being announced
last year with the short teaser that
gave us basically no information about
the game god of war ragnarok was finally
shown the new look at the game shows
kratos and atreus venturing through the
frozen lands of fimbo winter the deadly
winter ahead of the end of the world it
looks like their goal is to find the
norse god tier the trailer also showed a
bunch of returning characters from
2018's god of war as well as some new
threats including thor the god of
thunder who looks like he'll stand as an
antagonist to kratos and atreus there's
also the interpersonal relationship
between kratos and atreus who's hoping
to find out more about his identity as
loki spoilers following the events of
god of war and now let's rewind to the
very start of the showcase when
developer aspire announced a remake for
star wars knights of the old republic
the game got a very short teaser trailer
but considering how much of a classic
the original is it was enough to get a
lot of fans excited aspire has already
made a name for itself in the star wars
universe for making modern day ports of
popular star wars games like star wars
episode 1 racer star wars jedi knight 2
jedi outcast and star wars republic
commando knights of the republic remake
however is the studio's first blown
remake and as if those two games weren't
enough insomniac swoops in with not one
but
two games one of the games being the
sequel to spider-man which will feature
popular villain venom and the other a
surprise wolverine game
are you kidding me how does insomniac
have time to make all of these games
now if you missed any of playstation's
showcase like the insane for spoken
gameplay then you can get all caught up
on gamespot's youtube channel or over on
site at
gamespot.com but in the meantime let's
talk about some xbox news in a recent
blog post microsoft announced they're
adding next-gen controller features for
some older xbox controllers the new
firmware available only to some xbox
insiders will allow older xbox
controllers to use features previously
exclusive to the xbox series x and s the
game pads that can take advantage of the
new firmware include xbox one
controllers with bluetooth support xbox
elite series 2 and the xbox adaptive
controllers adding better cross-device
bluetooth connectivity and reduced
latency the cross-device bluetooth
connectivity uses bluetooth low energy
which allows for better connection to
pcs ios and android devices that support
it
it also allows the controller to
remember one bluetooth device and one
xbox controller letting people switch
between the two devices by double
tapping the sync button and in other
xbox related news halo has teamed up
with another energy drink company recall
last year microsoft and monster energy
teamed up to release cans that offered
double xp for halo infinite after the
game was delayed to 2021 microsoft
assured fans that any can they bought at
the time would be honored with double xp
when the game launches well now it's
rockstar energy's turn to help market
halo infinite as it nears its december
8th release date fans can get their
hands on the new collab starting october
1st however at the time of this
recording there is no details on if the
cans will feature halo infinite
unlockables are you into energy drinks
and if so comment your favorite down
below
and lastly i just want to mention that
action rpg neo is free right now on the
epic game store but don't worry you have
until september 16 to snag this surprise
freebie that received a 9 out of 10 from
us back in 2017. but all right that is
it for me what a great day starting off
with the like the matrix trailer in the
beginning of the day and then capping
off my day with all this fantastic
game news uh
just gotta soak it all in i gotta you
know i gotta make me some dinner and
just really just soak it all in
thanks for watching
[Music]
you